[Music]
and no means no news not submitted by a
Yelp reviewer oh [ __ ] you guys a chef is
suing the Michelin Guide for including
his restaurant against his wishes
that is surprising don't you want that
unless he doesn't want his business to
be like just [ __ ] flooded with the
kind of people that read Michelin
reviews yeah it's also like I didn't
want my movie I won an Oscar give it to
me for the money he must be in it for
just of love of The Fool it seems like
the Michelin star and [ __ ] right yeah I
was picturing the tire company it's the
same company but that's given but that's
the the same company is that high
regarded reward wait why are you are you
serious it was like a travel marketing
thing where it was like depending on how
many stars you get from the Michelin
rating it's like it's worth going to
that country just to eat that food yes
from wherever you live in the world it's
worth flying to that country eating that
and then turn around and flying home
it's like four stars three stars in this
three star they did a hella good job
with the brand in the food direction
right yeah no good years like the the
top one right mm-hmm everyone's like
Michelin shirts throw them on there I
guess there's a great tires I saw that I
start new bitchin Seoul South Korea and
so he is now suing the Michelin Guide
you might apakah they included his
restaurant in their 2019 edition I don't
want to be on that [ __ ] yeah I don't
wanna customize coming over exactly
by him asking for that and so he's
saying that like everyone is just like
shocked because like what a shock to you
literally everyone wants their
restaurants to be there it's like like
what you're saying it's like the Oscars
of food give me all the awards the parks
gonna work in taking it easy though yeah
right there's nothing worse than like
thinking you have a slow day like when
you work at Burger King like it's
Tuesday in pay days far away and then
it's packed you're like what that I did
sign up for this but he spending all
that time making it all good yes all for
no reason this is what he said he told
CNN this Michelin Guide is a cruel
system it's the cruelest test in the
world it forces the chef's to work
around a year waiting for a test a test
and they don't know when it's coming
it is humiliating to see my restaurant
given a rating in that unwholesome book
including my restaurant Oh in the
corrupt book is a defamation against
members of his restaurant and its fans
like a ghost they do not have a contact
number and I was only given I was only
able to get in touch through email
although I clearly refused listing my
restaurant they included it at their
will this year as well I don't
understand his argument he's like these
guys these guys are not right for coming
in and doing unbiased judgments of my
food without letting me know and come in
and unsupervised it's saying it's good
yeah I'd say that's guys you're missing
out this guy is so [ __ ] like
next-level in that marketing he's like
Brando when he refused the Academy Award
like you get you get offered the award
and then it's cool to be like I don't
even I don't even recognize a suit makes
it up here he had a [ __ ] Indian lady
accept the award on his behalf and she
like gave a speech or something a Native
American no she's Indian lady she's
wearing feathers everything
American Indian I didn't even know that
robber ten times cool that he like
double bird the whole Academy Awards and
then had this lady like like give a
speech without the Godfather yeah I mean
yeah the competition for that year I
mean he's great he's great but I mean I
feel like I heard the hype and I was
like man this
I mean he's maybe because he's so like
subdued can't compared to movies this
days you think it's also like he's the
archetype archetype of like what that
looks like that is true
that's the I make fun of it now it's
like a caricature what I'm think I'm
like man you know the guy like they do
that another movie now stuff the
continent all that [ __ ] right but at the
time they're like no this guy's freaking
killing it but he was also Malin [ __ ]
Brando then even McKee was already like
streetcar named desire Marlon Brando and
my eyelashes so you use just like [ __ ]
you I'm Marlon Brando which is so sick
Wow well that's I guess this guy's
probably doing that cuz he also said
there are thousands of restaurants and
soul that are on the same level or
better and more honest than those listed
on the michelin other people should I
got it my restaurant Oh was included in
this I'm gonna have so many current
restaurant customers at my restaurant oh
my step works so hard to prepare this
amazing food and now you degrade us with
an award stars how dare you
at my restaurant oh come to my
restaurant to boycott the Michelin Guide
and prove to them that they're not worth
my food and let them know it's mediocre
just do it just let them know he's
saying that he doesn't deserve it it's
just that he's like this guide is
[ __ ] so that he said that the sad
joke that a mere 170 of them are
representing Seoul numerous restaurants
and the workers are wasting away their
soul money time and effort to pursue the
Mirage that
Michelin star that's the spot like fine
dining or is it like a street stand pie
please
how much seems like I don't think
Michelin stars go to street stands they
do
yeah Michelin star today rate um just
based off how good the food is
unexperienced ooh
but but it's I don't think then you
stopped me so a Michelin star actually
is a good rating favourite it sucks
have you ever been I've been to multiple
and I think for me it's either I'm a
peasant and I don't understand food or
it [ __ ] sucks cuz three out of the
five restaurants maybe four [ __ ] suck
to me I went to a restaurant how Nova's
Michelin's our last night in LA that was
supposed to be like the chicest most la
thing and it was the worst food I've
ever yeah what the [ __ ] man currents and
flowers like it was a tasting menu thing
where you don't get to choose anything
right and they've been eating like seven
of like the 20 dishes had little flowers
in it I had a car and I felt so light
usually I hop but yeah oh yes
everything's edible they had like a
lobster that was like wrapped in rose
petals those like bro I'm not an animal
I don't want to eat flowers yes like
what head leaves and stuff are like bro
that's what a biscuit like you ordered
it it says it right here it's lobster
bouquet it was like kombucha if kombucha
was food it was that everything was oh
man it was so man we drop like 300 bucks
a head or some [ __ ] that's the worst the
lady that made the noodles she was a she
was mission star what no she wasn't just
came out on the Netflix show oh my god I
actually liked her dumplings what could
you ever heard of this place bizarre by
Jose Andres and like things they do all
this like fusion chant it's cool
but I went to Taco Bell after work
because I'm so [ __ ] hungry that's the
thing when you spend that much money I
at least want to feel for
but they're like no Americans you just
take a little bit whenever you go to
those fine dining places like yeah you
gotta be at least 50% full cuz I get it
before you go you mean no no I mean like
I want I want enough food to where I
feel satisfied tour I'm like alright I
don't need an e I don't want to be
stuffed because like I did go to a
wedding like with Casey's cousin in Hong
Kong we like they were catered by a
one-star Michelin restaurant and it was
like 20 million courses or like I can't
[ __ ] fit any more food even though
it's like one or two bites each you just
like grow enough it was really good my
claim jumpers are sick dude the biscuits
bigger than the whole [ __ ] plate then
they bring another plate with the with
the steak and it's bigger than the
biscuit plate I love to claim jumpers I
just want a lot of it me too it's like
this is 18 potato the plates are huge
chopped onion food we ate on the claim
only gives you too much food
yes I don't one taco and that's enough
for ten tacos I don't like it Chipotle's
not known for their volume you get one
taco in tips like I have it watches
these cats like dick like chicken you
know how they do that a toy they take
the chicken and they put a little tiny
little sprinkle and I'm like what the
[ __ ] told the whole spoon in their level
stupid be like level it out yeah just
like put it in the salt shaker they're
like putting little bit of chicken just
like that is more than nothing yeah
that's too much food do much okay anyway
so this is the chef that's a suing
Michelin Guide wait he's suing them
feeling it right there for defamation I
don't know that you have our case
usually I said something negative about
you right yeah it's like you'd have to
like he'd have to prove that they hurt
his business in some way they helped his
business know all right
so he was saying that it's actually so
there was this lawyer that's saying that
in order for him to win this case they
have to prove that in the publication
they used like a curse word against him
to for him to even oh it's called
they're saying that they would have used
profanity in the description of his
restaurant and or otherwise negatively
affect his social standing which wasn't
the case yeah so that's what he's trying
to sue for that's the first time I ever
heard of Korean not be number one they
broke a South Korean law against public
insult that's what it is so oh right
because a lot of Yelp kind of food
review places there we're getting taken
down because they didn't like um like
public opinion on their restaurants and
reviewing and stuff yeah oh yeah I don't
know that's what he's doing I gotta go
now I gotta see what all the fuss is
about where you were you insult to me
feel like this friend is Sarah even my
compliment Mike this is great see this
is what Michelin did now he likes the
food
man you came up with room a to them
liked it
now you might come back again YouTube
video about it
do take the corniest [ __ ] recording
artists in the world
have them send their Grammy back and
they're my [ __ ] hero nobody will do
it right I know I'll do it oh that is so
[ __ ] cool
[Music]